this video sponsored by Ray Con earbuds
you ever run around in breath of the
wild and just go I mean there are giant
ribs sticking out of the ground this
huge dragon head fainting in a pit of
quicksand and probably the most
well-known of Hyrule's bony artifacts
the Leviathan carcasses spread out in
the different corners of the world and
wouldn't you know it every single one of
these fossilized monstrosities is you
know unexplained in true breadth of the
wild fashion of course but that has
absolutely not stopped us from
theorizing about their identities over
the past three years with the three
Leviathan corpses being the most popular
to talk about and you know speaking of
which since you clicked on this video
you've probably figured out by now that
that's actually what this video will be
about but not all of the why things just
one the most interesting one to me the
ice Leviathan you know the one I'm
talking about the one that's inside that
cave in the Hebrew location that has a
shrine in it that you have to access by
rolling a snowball down a hill puzzle
yes a hill puzzle and ram into some
ancient stone doors yeah that Leviathan
not only is the location of this
Leviathan incredibly strange but it
could also give a hint as to what or
even who this giant flying whale used to
be when it swam amongst the living and
I'm incredibly excited to announce that
I'm going to be joined by a friend for
this theory even though he's new on the
scene he's been making waves and turning
heads with his incredible content so far
I am pleased to welcome monster maze
hello there it's me monster maze and I
am glad to be here at the end of this
video be sure to hop on over to my
channel right together we will explored
a much needed addition of underwater
traversal in breadth of the wild - now
before we get into the content of this
bone-chilling theory I just wanted to
thank you for watching and inform you
that you can make sure you defeat being
at the mercy of the YouTube algorithm
and always catch my newest theories by
making sure you're subscribed to the
channel with that Belon so you never
miss out my analytics tell me that over
80 percent of my viewers actually are
not subscribed so do yourself a favor
and double check real quick also leave a
like on this year video if you find
yourself enjoying what we've created
anyway without further ado let's delve
into the mystery behind the ice
Leviathan
take it away monster man
the Leviathan bones of ruff of the wild
are some of the strangest landmarks in a
game full of you know strange landmarks
but even stranger still is the Leviathan
we actually find indoors literally on
the inside of these giant stone doors
leading into the mountain you see as
bandid was mentioning earlier two out of
the three Leviathan corpses are found
just out in the open
one being located down south in the
Gerudo desert region and the other being
found on the northeastern edge of the
map just on the other side of the Death
Mountain area however the final
Leviathan the hey bruh Leviathan isn't
like the other two no to get to this
that beastie you have to go through a
door that's been carved into the side of
the mountain once you snow smash your
way through this door you enter into a
massive chamber filled with icy
stalagmites a shrine and oh yeah the ice
Leviathan
now the first reaction that most people
have to discovering this large debt fish
is the exact same as discovering any of
them but once you take a closer look at
everything surrounding the leviathans
positioning and even the nature of the
cave itself you'll find that the ice
Leviathan has literally been hidden away
from the rest of the world for an
unknown amount of time and suddenly it
becomes way more interesting but just
how interesting mr. bandit uh bandit you
there hmm
oh right yes sorry I was looking up your
use of the word stalagmite turns out you
did use it correctly as a stalactite
forms from the ceiling instead yes yes I
know oh good what makes ice ease
positioning so interesting is first the
question of how it even got here as in
inside this cave you see looking at the
only visible entrance to this cave for
some reason I find it hard to believe
that this ex whale just waltzed in here
through the doorway I mean I don't know
something about it just doesn't make
sense to me but since it obviously
didn't come in through the door how else
would it have ended up inside this cave
one might be tempted to say that it
simply died in the great outdoors the
same as the other two leviathans we find
in the map and that maybe it ended up in
this cave because this mountain actually
formed around the giant deceased body
and was not present
the time of its death so that's it then
right well obviously I'm about to say no
that's not what happened
and here's how we know that for sure one
the ice Leviathan you know what I'm
tired of trying to come up with a new
unique name for this thing every time I
mention it let's call it Shamu
let's call it Shamu um you want to call
a giant whale trapped inside a tightly
spaced cave Shamu isn't that a little I
don't know insensitive
oh right hmm
well how about I don't know Sparky
that works okay so one Sparky is in a
cave that's in a mountain but the others
are not right as I was just talking
about you might be tempted to say that
this is because maybe the icy Mountain
formed around the body overtime but if
that were the case why are there not
also large rock formations or caverns
surrounding the other two now it's
possible that Sparky died long before
the other two I mean there's nothing
that states they all died at the same
time so if it's just a matter of
thousands of cubic feet of rock forming
over the course of many many years then
sure it could just be because Sparky
might be older than the other two but
let me add another layer to this to
further state my point Sparky is found
inside a cave emphasis on inside the
cave not a part of the cave you see if
rocks were to form around Sparky after
it died then the bone structure of
Sparky would actually act as formative
points for the newly forming rocks in
other words Sparky would be a part of
the mountain itself instead of just
sitting comfortably inside interesting
isn't it
that must mean that this cave existed
prior to Sparky skeleton being inside it
I mean yes part of the right-fin of the
Sparky skeleton is inside the cave wall
but that might be due to ice forming
over time since the wall is partially
rock and partially ice as evidenced by
link being able to climb it but while it
also visually appears to consist of a
different material than just standard
Rock so the whale didn't get here
through the doorway and it didn't get
here by just dying and having Rock form
around it how else did it get here in
that case what a great question bandit
I'd like to point out that there's
actually another way that the Leviathan
could have entered the cave
you
you know why can't life be like video
games see in video games you could put
like cheat codes in and stuff like that
and make things a lot easier for you
and sometimes in life you need a cheat
code one of the ways to escape the
mundanity of this world is to maybe
watch a zelda video on the internet
every now and then or be able to
wirelessly listen to your favorite tunes
well luckily for you I happen to have a
very important life hack for you that
I'm excited to share introducing the
rape on everyday e25 earbuds by Ray J
and actually at this point it's not even
an introduction I mean you guys know I
love these earbuds I've done these
videos what like about three times now
or so honestly and this is my honest
opinion this is about as good as it gets
with wireless sound quality they have
fantastic base for listening to your
favorite Zelda fans they deliver this
premium audio quality at just about half
the price of other premium earbuds on
the market you can just put them in and
forget about them because they have six
hours of play time and their cute little
charging case comes with four complete
charges before you ever have to plug it
back in and of course my favorite
quality are the colors that they come in
if you want to follow in my footsteps
and hack your way to better audio here's
my cheat code for you click the link in
the description below or go to WWE
no no please no thanks required it's
what I do
now this offer is only around for a
limited amount of time so what are you
waiting for go check today and now back
to the video and now back to the video
hey Jordan Jordan
Jordan yeah what is it back to the video
okay mr. Bennet whatever you say if you
look below the Leviathans skeleton
Sparkie right if you look below Sparkie
skeleton you'll see a small body of
water now this is peculiar given the
frigid temperatures surrounding the
outside and inside of the cave and if we
take a look at the map well inside the
cave the temperatures reach lower than
negative 40 degrees Fahrenheit which is
way colder than the freezing point of
water this tiny body of water should
have transformed into solid ice long ago
but obviously it's not freezing for some
reason the only way that a body of water
would maintain its liquid state in a
place like this frigid cavern is if the
water itself were actually a higher
temperature than its environment and
this phenomenon is only possible if one
the water is constantly moving because
motion generates energy which generates
heat or - if the water we see is
actually part of a much larger body of
water beneath the surface which would
prevent the water from freezing over and
as we can see this liquid state h2o is
barely moving and yet it's still in a
non frozen state which according to
science means that the only way it's
remaining on frozen must be because it's
actually much deeper than we are allowed
to see in game since you know this is
the first time since the link to the
past that we actually haven't been able
to go on the water in a Zelda game that
features water so when you combine this
with what bandit was talking about
regarding the difference between this
and the other leviathan locations and
surroundings it is our belief that this
body of water here which must be much
deeper than what we're shown is where
Sparky came from the speculation here is
that this connects to some sort of
massive underground water system that
this Leviathan could have used to enter
this little cave and ultimately died
here either by choice or because it
couldn't leave so that's it case closed
nothing else to talk about here right
bandit well there is one more thing oh
what's that well we know how Sparky got
there but what about taking a shot at
who or what Sparky used to be when it
was alive oh right well do you mind if I
take this one be my guest
all right so you know how you have to
enter through a paved path and doorway
to get into this cave and the first
thing you see is this skeleton well to
me that really reminds me of a place of
worship probably designed around Sparky
itself I mean there's even a sheikah
shrine that was constructed here inside
this random literal door in the side of
the mountain this place could be
considered sacred if it was a place of
worship for leviathans who have always
been heralded as benevolent deities in
the zelda lore such as the wind fish
having the power to create a universe
within his dream or jabu jabu who is
also a wind fish Leviathan as seen by
his rather giant nature and his little
wings beside his ears and who was also
worshipped as a deity by the Zora so
what if this cave was a place of worship
for Sparky and what if what if this is
like a fairy fountain where a great
fairy normally pops out of but in this
case it was actually Sparky and since
Sparky is a whale and clearly swims
around in the water or I mean used to
swim around in the water
what if Sparky is a descendant of the
one and only water Leviathan named jabu
jabu from ocarina of time who also was
worshipped in an extremely similar
manner which would make sense of this
obviously man-made doorway and path an
even location of the chicest shrine as
some sort of ancient place of worship
for the ice Leviathan yeah that's uh
that's what I was going to say whoops I
get a little carried away sometimes
after all this is all pretty speculative
but it's very interesting to say the
least I'm glad we finally have a
decently solid theory about the Ice
leviathans strangely specific location
it's been bothering me for like three
years now anyway next up I wanted to
talk about what that underwater section
may mean for breadth of the wild to like
could you imagine if there's a dungeon
down there no we talked about that in my
video remember oh yeah right speaking of
which be sure to catch the other part of
this collab over on monster mazes
channel links will be in the description
below hey guys thank you so much for
watching do you think we're onto
something regarding the strange
appearance of Sparky the ice Leviathan
or are we way off let me know in the
comments below it was an absolute
pleasure to be here thanks a lot for
having me on and thank all of you for
watching just as a quick reminder this
is a two-parter so head over to my
channel and see
we have cooking they're huge things is
always to my fantastic supporters of
which I have a couple new faces
please welcome SEPA vick thomas a
michael l and some g to my elite crew if
you're interested in joining the channel
and receiving some epic benefits click
the join button below or follow the link
in the description to find out how also
down there are my links to the social
media pages i sometimes am slightly
active on so come on over and experience
my slight lead sometimes active activity
or at least my Instagram because I just
post pictures of my adorable dogs there
anyway this is mass antenna bandits
signing out have a great rest of your
day
[Music]